yeah
well you know everybody wanted a vaccine
at that time and I was able to do
something that nobody else could have
done getting it done very very rapidly
but I never was for mandates I was I
thought the mandates were terrible
and
and you know there's a big portion of
the country that thinks that was a great
thing
some people think the vaccine was a good
thing you know I would have loved to
have seen Trump say when she says we've
lost a lot of people because you
supported the jab Trump goes yeah
I would have preferred Trump to say
what do you mean we've lost a lot of
people because I supported the job what
exactly are you talking about